people I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it is February 14th are you
feeling the love it is Valentine's Day I
hope you eat chocolate and get laid
tonight we are live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals if you get luck late
during the day that's fine too wherever
it works out for you guys just fine
enjoy it hope you have somebody that you
love hope you love somebody and if you
don't
get cracking time is of the essence
that's the point uh we do a post game
show every day it's going to be very
lovey-dovey today at
reubenreport.locals.com and I think
we're just going to dive right into the
show today because we have a jam-packed
program with all sorts of notes and
things and I check mark things when I
think they're particularly good if you
are playing along on Twitter you may
have noticed that uh over the last day
and a half or so I've been going pretty
hard on this organization known as News
Guard which is a lefty non-profit though
funded by the government I'll have the
receipts for you in just a moment and
they have been reaching out because they
want to do a big piece on the Reuben
report they don't like me very much and
they want to find out about our
journalistic integrity and a whole bunch
more now interestingly this all started
yesterday yesterday was Monday now
you've never heard me talk about News
Guard on the show except that on Friday
last Friday Marissa stripe the CEO of
prageru was on our panel paddle show
with Viva fry and David sacks and she
mentioned how newsguard funded by the
government has been going after prageru
so interestingly that is the first time
they've ever been mentioned on the
Reuben report and then Monday morning
we get an email they're looking into us
well I am not taking it lying down and I
have gone off on these Freaks and losers
and today I'm going to destroy them
before I do that I want to talk to you
about leaky guts okay and then we'll get
to the destruction you guys know that
leaky gut is caused by a toxin that's in
all the quote healthy foods that
scientists have been telling us to eat
with a fraudulent food pyramid for the
longest time this toxin according to Dr
gundry a world-renowned cardiologist is
affecting millions of people Nationwide
warning signs include weight gain and
fatigue and digestive discomfort and
stiff and achy joints even skin problems
these side effects are often mistaken
for normal signs of aging because leaky
gut develops usually over a matter of
years and sometimes even decades the
good news is this can be easily fixed
from your own home it's very simple you
just have to know which foods are
actually healthy and which contain this
hidden toxin after years of research Dr
country has decided to release an
informative video to the public for free
do I have a website to send these fine
people to we're going to post a link in
the description down below it's gut
cleanseprotocol.com Dave there's the
doctor with an avocado avocados are good
for you there you go all right so I want
to really get into the collusion and
what I always tell you guys is the LIE
laundering between the non-profits the
ngos the government big Tech big media
how they have pushed so much nonsense on
us and then the few people that push
back they label misinformation
experts and well no they don't label us
misinformation experts they say they're
the misinformation experts they label us
misinformation and disinformation I
don't know assassins or something like
that
um while we try to push back on their
drivel and it's happening faster it
really is escalating very very fast the
level of nonsense and our ability to
basically expose their lies and
everything else so I want to frame all
of this around a funny thing we saw on
CNN CNN which of course uh is
unintentionally funny uh there was Don
Lemon and you remember Don Lemon he had
the nighttime show nobody was watching
so instead of firing him they gave him
the morning show now the morning show
has the worst ratings I think in CNN's
history but Don still gets up there with
his fake newsman glasses pretends to be
a journalist uh here he is discussing uh
you saw it we played a clip yesterday at
the Super Bowl very very scary stuff do
we have any kind of warning for this
level of scary stuff do we have any
scary we don't have a Halloween warning
or a scary sound it was very very scary
so so please I'm warning you
Elon Musk was sitting in a box with
Rupert Murdoch this is this is freaky
scary stuff and and Don's not happy
about it assistant and you see Elon Musk
um and Rupert Murdoch sitting there
together that gets people to wonder and
for some it is confirmation that see
that's why he shouldn't have done the
interview with Fox it's all they're all
in collusion out to get Joe Biden and
and liberals and the administration I
mean it is kind of in a musk has sort of
positioned himself as this rebel against
traditional media sitting next to you
know one of the great media Moguls of
our era who has these vast Holdings
maybe most interesting you know
Murdoch's daughter Elizabeth a prominent
media executive sitting next to musk who
is theoretically currently in the search
for a CEO to replace himself which I
don't I think she's sort of an
interesting candidate for that gig were
you that surprised though to see them
sitting next to each other I really I
don't think I was that surprised it
stood out but it wasn't like oh wow no
it seems like the most predictable thing
in the world I was kind of surprised
that they actually like wow they
actually did it because it's a little
fresh lightning I must wow it's a little
frightening two guys sitting next to
each other peacefully probably eating
hot dogs could really freak you out you
know that is scary stuff but there's a
reason that lemon is scared obviously oh
by the way that the guy there that they
were bringing on is the analyst that guy
Ben Smith I don't know it said under his
name he's something of semaphore I don't
know what the hell that is but he used
to be the CEO of BuzzFeed so this guy is
like a full-on trash
journalist that's all he is he also has
that weird that asexual affect that I
keep talking about I don't know why it
is that these guys on TV have to talk
like this like maybe they could talk
like adults but for some reason if they
come off as completely asexual then
somehow people think that if they're
saying something nice because they sort
of have that Trudeau thing I don't know
anyway why is lemon afraid that a big
Tech guy who's coming in and saying hey
I'd like an even playing field and I'd
like more voices to be heard and we're
not gonna ban People based on political
views and we're going to have a more
transparent terms of service and things
of that nature why is he so freaked out
that that guy would be sitting next to a
media Mogul now obviously he doesn't
like Rupert Murdoch because everybody's
watching Fox for the set of people that
still watch cable news and there are a
certain set of people that still do it's
increasingly less obviously people are
tuning out you know cutting the cord and
all that sort of thing now you can get
Fox digitally but the point is people
are watching cable news as a whole less
but they really have left CNN they've
really left MSNBC and Fox News is still
getting millions and millions of viewers
on every program so he obviously doesn't
like Rupert Murdoch so the idea of the
Free Speech guy sitting down with the
media guy who's controlling the network
that people watch that's scary because
what could happen Don Lemon with his
low-rated Morning Show could lose the
narrative and all they have is the
narrative uh here is video of Matt taibi
Matt taibi is an actual journalist you
know him he is the one that released the
first edition
of the Twitter file so Elon brought him
into Twitter you may remember that first
round of Twitter files he also brought
in Barry Weiss Michael schellenberger a
couple other people said to them here's
what's going on here you guys can do
whatever you want with this information
the only thing that I ask is that you
release it on Twitter that jives with my
experience with Elon which was I sat
down with him for a couple hours and all
he said was hey you could say whatever
you want as long as it's true so this
guy is actually trying to restore
journalism that would freak out and be
very frightening for a guy like Don
Lemon and his cohorts at CNN anyway here
is Matt taibi explaining Hamilton
68 okay now I really this is you're
gonna have to jump with me on this one
for just a moment he's explaining
Hamilton 68 this dashboard that was used
for disinformation and and watch this
and then we're going to show you how it
actually was used you'll see what I'm
doing here I promise yeah so the key
here is that they built this tool called
The Hamilton 68 dashboard that purported
to track Russian Bots again it was based
on 644 accounts which we now know are
mostly organic accounts mostly real
people mostly in the west uh but they
would say these accounts are now
following let's just say the hashtag
fire McMaster or hashtag release the
memo or hashtag I stand with Laura or
hashtag Parkland shooting and then you
would see a flood of news stories come
out in the next day maybe in the New
York Times maybe the Washington Post
maybe CNN maybe MSNBC that would say
Russian Bots are supporting this hashtag
in reality there were no Russians or
there were very few Russians let's put
it that way most of these were actual
Real Americans who were just doing
ordinary conversations on Twitter so
Mike Morrell let's look at those four
again uh Mike McFall an ambassador to
Russia certainly is credibility Mike
morale used to brief Bush as well as
Barack Obama CIA guy and then a podesta
as left-wing as it gets was supposed to
be the cheapest half Hillary Clinton ran
her campaign uh and Clint watts and
MSNBC contributor so he could continue
this this false reporting as so-called
experts in Russian bots on another News
Network okay this is seriously important
stuff because this is how the lies get
laundered so those guys that they showed
up that they showed the images of right
there they create this dashboard called
Hamilton 68 to make it seem like Russian
Bots are running rampant and affecting
our elections and everything else and
it's completely untrue now we're going
to show you a compilation of mainstream
media circulating the idea that Hamilton
68 has something to do with Russians and
Bots this is just wild right so taivi is
reporting the truth the truth is these
guys came up with this dashboard it had
nothing to do with the Russians Now
watch how the media has been reporting
on this for weeks and months actually
Twitter tracking tool that's called
Hamilton 68 they're now reporting that
Twitter accounts linked to Russian
influence operations well they've been
upping the frequency with which they're
promoting this hashtag release the memos
uh there's a dashboard Hamilton 68 named
after the Federalist Paper uh Alexander
Hamilton's Federalist paper which
focused on Election meddling and
protecting the process which focuses on
Twitter feeds and has determined that
Russia was indeed or sites alleged to be
connected with Russia were interfering
in the Alabama election russian-linked
Twitter accounts tried using the tragedy
to stoke the nation's political divides
Kremlin linked accounts flooded Twitter
using hashtags like Parkland and gun
control now to get into trending
conversations according to data
collected by the non-partisan Dashboard
Hamilton 68. the bad news is the
Russians are continuing to attack our
democracy do you guys get it like again
it's one of those those things once you
see it you see it everywhere it had
nothing to do with Russian Bots these
guys Bill Crystal McFall these guys came
up with this thing to point everything
at Russian Bots does that sound kind of
familiar remember we had a couple uh
impeachment hearings from that orange
man and all that stuff so why am I
mentioning all of this well at the top
of the show I mentioned that News Guard
is going after me News Guard is one of
these sort of non-profit organizations
that use a name called newsguard makes
it sounds like it makes it sound like
they're guarding the news like they're
good guys although it's a bit ironic
sort of like reliable sources who are
actually unreliable sources and what
they do is they look at TV shows they
look at websites and now they look at
podcasts apparently that's new as of
yesterday
um to decide are these people being
truthful but of course as you know and
we will now lay out the case they are a
bunch of partisan hacks and they are
getting government dollars to look into
private citizens I'm a private citizen
they're looking into me so how did this
all start well on Friday I had prageru
CEO Marissa stright on the show and she
mentioned that News Guard has been
looking into them now before I show you
the clip why would newsguard be doing
this so they can put you on a list right
so they say Prager you bad they put you
on a list and then what their hope is is
that they can get that list to the New
York Times which is always what happens
nobody pays nobody reads these little
News Guard things you've never heard of
News Guard before Friday right but what
they do is they they come out with their
study which is completely fraudulent the
New York Times then reports on it and
then other companies advertisers
whatever it might be they go all right
you know what actually we're just not
going to work with prageru we're not
going to you know license them our video
player we're not going to put ads on
their programming etc etc So This Is How
They launder the lies and do their Mafia
tactics so let's go to the beginning of
this this is how it started this is just
on Friday again I had never mentioned
News Guard on the show before uh here is
prageru CEO Marissa strike talking about
what's going on with News Guard I pray
for you Marissa I'm sure none of this
surprises you because you guys at Prager
you when we talk about censorship you
guys have been in lawsuits with Google
and YouTube before and been fighting the
the algorithmic tricks and all that
stuff for for quite some time
well I think that's where Jim Jordan was
trying to reach he's trying to figure
out and really highlight to the public
and to Congress how involved these media
companies have been with the government
and this is one of the issues that we
have had when we've sued YouTube and now
we have these issues with newsguard the
answer that we keep getting when we're
experiencing censorship is that these
are free you know these are companies
they are free agents they're allowed to
do whatever they want to do and we keep
highlighting the fact that there is
government intervention it's just we
can't seem to to grasp where it's coming
from and and hopefully these
Congressional hearings but more so more
investigation and I agree we need to
start asking the FBI why are media
companies like mine uh have felt so much
pressure to censor to self-censor uh and
not just self-censor when we produce
content about climate or about the
lockdowns I don't call but I call it the
lockdowns why have we been threatened
with being you know basically you know
taken off the internet entirely okay so
one of the things that happened to
prageru after News Guard wrote a piece
about them said that they were very
scary is that JW player which is one of
the video players that's on a lot of the
websites so not you know YouTube has its
own native video player Rumble has its
own native video player but if you go to
a random website they use they license a
player a video player from somebody else
JW player who's sort of the ubiquitous
one that's on most of these websites
they broke their relationship with
prageru after News Guard went after them
so that's what she's talking about you
go for you put these scary ideas out
there Prager use somehow misinformation
and their mean right-wing people and
then other organizations they start
getting freaked out because we live in
this bizarre time of cancel culture
which we're trying to extricate
ourselves out of and then you start
losing your ability to put your videos
up or sell ads on your stuff or whatever
it might be so anyway that was Friday
again I have never referenced newsguard
on the show I don't give a flying F
about News Guard until they come for me
so on Monday morning my assistant Daphne
forwarded me this email
dear Daphne I'm Zach Fishman and I'm a
reporter with newsguard a service that
reviews news and information websites
and television shows for credibility and
transparency these reviews which include
a written summary and a checklist of
criteria are intended to help readers
have more context for the news they
consume we are in the process of
expanding our purview to podcasts how
bizarre they're suddenly doing that the
Monday after I mention them and I'm
currently writing a review of the Reuben
report is someone available to answer
some questions I have about the content
aired on the show as a heads up we
incorporate quotes from our
correspondences into our published
reviews so this conversation should be
considered on the record thank you in
essence Mafia tactic you have a very
nice podcast don't you over there be a
shame if anything happened to your
podcast so you better play ball with us
so once Daphne forwarded me that email
she said how would you like to handle
this I thought about it for about 12
seconds and then I tweeted this
I found the guy on Twitter uh Hey ZB
Fishman my assistant passed along your
email and there's a copy of the email so
I wanted to go on the record for you and
newsguard as requested quote who on the
government instructs your policies and
where do you get your funding your mafia
tactics won't work on me print that it's
on the record poop emoji clown Emoji end
quote so first off I really hope when
they do the report the poop emoji and
the clown Emoji get in there that really
was the key to the whole thing anyway
that got a lot of traction okay people
start retweeting it commenting on it
because people have had it with these
people people don't want this nonsense
organizations that are funded partly by
the government we'll get to that in a
second and then all these you know
left-wing ngos and non-profits they
funnel funnel all they funnel all of
this money to silence anyone who is
outside of the narrative so Zach Fishman
responded to Daphne he sent another
email hello Daphne I've seen the
questions that Dave Rubin posted on his
Twitter account to answer them newsguard
is editorially independent and does not
receive instructions from the US
government notice he didn't say they
don't receive funds we'll get to that in
a minute you can read more on why should
you trust us page of our website for
information about news guards funding
see our investors page I've written down
my questions for the Reuben Court below
if Reuben or anyone else at the show
would like to provide comment so now we
I had Phoenix go into this email he
wanted to know a zillion things about
the show and what I've done so I'm just
going to read a couple of these now can
you put the camera back on me for a
second before I read this to you guys
I've said a million times on this show I
am not a journalist a journalist is a
fact finder out there on the street
traveling trying to talk to direct
sources to tell an honest story what I
do is I see the news I ingest it and I
and I tell it back to you guys I clearly
have my opinions like I am not
pretending I think the difference here
the difference between say a me and a
Don Lemon Don Lemon also talks to the
camera tells people The Daily News
similar to what I do but I'm not
pretending that I'm impartial I'm
telling you what my opinions are my my
evolution is very much out there we did
that whole uh 25 minute video last week
my the four videos that I've done for
Prague you completely talking about how
I've evolved politically I make it clear
when I'm supporting a candidate or when
I like somebody or I don't like somebody
my cards are completely on the table
here so now a couple of the comments
that Fishman wanted to know about the
Reuben report so that they could write
their very negative reviews so it get in
the New York Times then people would
stop working with us I noticed that
discussions of significant issues on the
show are dominated by conservative
conservative opinion
with the podcast regularly neglecting to
provide alternative viewpoints on these
topics I've listed some examples below
do you believe that the podcast
overwhelmingly airs one-sided commentary
well come back to me for a sec so first
off I try for a long time when I was on
the left I was getting people on the
left and the right on once I started
bringing people on the right on all the
lefties started screaming that I was a
homophobe and a bigot and a racist and a
transform and everything else so it is
increasingly difficult to get people on
the left on that being said I don't know
if you've seen it yet but we just did an
interview last week we posted part one
this morning with my buddy Pete bagozian
Pete is a lefty a liberal he watched the
State of the Union Address and thought
Biden did a good job and we sat down and
agreed to disagree but we went into each
of our opinions on that anyway I can do
my show as I see fit but what this guy
is trying to do is he wants to be able
to write a scary Reuben's scary right
winger scary right Winger don't work
with Reuben next up on the 11 5 22
episode Reuben interviewed Republican
gubernatorial candidate Tudor Dixon
openly supported her candidacy while
criticizing Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer with her and did not present the
perspective of any Dixon critics in his
questions uh well I interview people the
way I see fit it's my show my
name's in the title dude come and get me
number four
that was ineffective I feel like that
was you know because I'm trying to with
death bombs but that one I felt was like
you know we know who show this is all
right number four I found multiple
instances when Reuben said that the
covid-19 vaccines don't work I got one
more for you fishermen they don't work
there I said it today the Valentine's
Day February 14th for example on the
13123 episode while discussing a poll
showing how low enthusiasm in Australia
for the fourth dose of covid vaccines
Reuben said the vaccines don't work none
of this works do you guys get it yet yes
while I was talking about the fourth
vaccine that they want these people to
get and on the 123-23 episode while
discussing a 2021 Australian government
advertisement that depicted a gasping
woman on a ventilator and promoted
covid-19 vaccines Reuben said that was
the government doing that to their own
people get vaccinated now it turns out
vaccines don't work yes they don't work
vaccines do not stop you from getting
covid nor transmitting covid and there
is no widespread evidence that you will
get lesser covid if you are vaccinated
actually I just had Robert Malone on who
is the inventor of mRNA technology and
he thinks it's degrading people's immune
systems and they are are going to get
far worse vaccine injuries than we're
even seeing now so a little a little
bizarre it's interesting though he
didn't reference any of the episodes
where I provide receipts for my vaccine
comments and all that here's another one
and then we'll we'll stop belaboring the
point I think you're getting it on the
424-22 episode yes Carrie late claimed
that widespread fraud caused Arizona's
electoral votes to be stolen from Donald
Trump in the 2020 election without
pushback from Reuben she said we've had
millions of election files deleted we've
had election and state laws that were
broken we've had 740 000 ballots that
contain no chain of custody president
Trump I believe won Arizona by a
landslide well I'm an interviewer and I
interviewed Carrie Lake and those are
her opinions and she fought very hard in
her election was which was subsequent to
that in her own gubernatorial election
she fought very hard it doesn't seem
like it's going well through the courts
but she is entitled to her opinion you
douchebag everything she said in essence
she believed to be true I don't fact
check people in real time if someone
says something like completely egregious
that I know to be untrue I I can mention
that but I am an interviewer are you
saying that every interviewer should sit
down with someone and be fact-checking
them live in that moment and by the way
she literally carry like literally said
in my opinion
opinion so anyway he sent those
questions and again because he said
everything's on the record I'm thinking
why would I respond to this on an email
let's roll dude let's do this publicly
so here here in this one I was a little
uh a little Saucier I think uh Hey ZB
Fishman got your follow-up email once
again I'll respond in public and on the
record you're not a journalist you're an
activist rat I do my show as I see fit
don't like it don't watch and get a life
you obsessive dork please print that
verbatim thanks I I know I know
everyone's like I get it I get it am I
being like a bit much here but I don't
think really because these people have
to pay for this stuff enough of this so
all right News Guard you seem to want
receipts about things you seem to want
and fishmen and you Media Matters losers
and you Southern Poverty Law Center
freaks you're all watching this trying
to figure out how to take me out so
let's just roll through what it is you
guys are doing over there at news at
News Guard well prageru also is not just
sitting there and taking this crap from
them so they have a page on the prageru
website that explains what News Guard
actually is and who's who they're
partnered with and here we go you're
gonna love this one guys who's behind
News Guard News Guard is partnered with
big tech companies like Microsoft big
Pharma like the pr firm for Pfizer the
maker of the covid vaccine government
agencies like the Department of Defense
and even uh teachers unions like the
American Federation of teachers to quote
combat disinformation especially around
covid-19 and elections are according to
the world economic Forum they want to
control the narrative on any and every
topic from climate change covid-19
treatments and vaccines to elections
Planned Parenthood and the wef to name
just a few so now this is really
beautiful so I tweet all this stuff out
right and and this guy he has no
followers News Guard has no followers
but again they're not trying to get this
out there via Twitter what they do is
they put these false studies together
and then their cohorts in the New York
Times literally printed
in the New York Times and then Democrat
politicians run around saying you see
disinformation misinformation we have to
censor more people so anyway my tweets
were catching fire and Brendan Leslie
who is in charge of Florida's voice they
are an actual independent journalist
outfit here in Florida he did absolutely
Brandon's a great guy we're gonna get
him on the show he he did great great
work in Southwest Florida after the
hurricane uh he texted me this morning
and he said Dave you know I saw your
your tweets about this it's funny
because another guy at newsguard has
been going on after me uh and I got him
to admit in an email that they do take
money from the government so he sent me
the email here you go this is someone
named Samuel Howard going after uh
Brandon Leslie it is true that a minor
portion of our Revenue comes from small
Federal contracts begun during the Trump
Administration to provide reports on
Russian and other state-sponsored
disinformation I hardly think this makes
me a Fed any more than someone working
with a utility that supplies electricity
phone or Internet services to the
government makes that person a Fed I do
hope you will respond to our questions
Brendan obviously is not responding to
those questions he did send me that now
it's interesting he's saying that
they're just getting a little bit of
money well it took me all of 30 seconds
to do something on the computer I opened
up my computer you guys know I don't
like to open my computer that often I'm
doing most of my stuff on the phone but
I opened up my computer
what's going on with this thing here we
go from USA spending this is the
official
usaspending.gov website a purchase order
from the Department of Defense to
newsguard Technologies for 750 000 that
ain't nothing so the government you not
you really need to understand this and
this is so consistent with the Twitter
files and everything we are finding out
in every which way the government pays
this place called newsguard to take out
voices they don't like with these false
nonsensical ridiculous questions go
going after opinion makers and things of
that nature and then they get it into
the New York Times and then this is how
they do their their sensorious lunacy
this is how they do it uh also it's a
it's a very poor analogy that he gave
there because electricians are not
contracted to combat dissidents of the
government electricians generally uh
they connect things so that you get
power to your TV for example but this is
happening everywhere and it's bursting
forth all over the place I saw this
tweet by Gabe Kaminsky this morning new
disinformation Inc the state department
backed National Endowment for democracy
granted over 315 000 in 2021 to the
global disinformation index which is
secretly blacklisting conservative news
so you can see guys this is happening
all over the place also my buddy clay
Travis you guys know Clay Travis from
outtick.com he had a long thread this
morning the Brookings Institute has been
funding all of this research going after
after him and uh and Buck Sexton you
know Clay and buck they replaced Rush
Limbaugh on the radio so that's a real
threat right because they have a counter
Viewpoint than the predominant let's say
left-wing liberal Viewpoint that these
people want out there uh so the Brooking
Institute has been going after them with
a well-funded attack and it's like we
must expose this nonsense it still is
confusing these people it still is
confusing your friend who no doesn't
watch this show doesn't listen to Clay
and buck but they you know what they are
they they drink their coffee on a Sunday
morning with their cat on their shoulder
and they read the New York Times because
they're very bright while they're
sitting on the Upper East Side and they
go my God honey you're not going to
believe this news guards said that Dave
Rubin is a mean dude we best not watch
his program
and that is the way they enable the
nonsense and when you wonder why reality
is so disconnected from where what we're
getting in the media this is exactly why
and the fact that News Guard is
connected to the world economic Forum
which gives me a heck of a segue we're
going to show you Palpatine himself
here's Klaus Schwab saying that the
world will no longer be run by the USA
instead he's got plans for the wef and
uh BlackRock okay
who will really commence for cinder's
Revolution and its technology like
artificial intelligence what's your
sense of who's best placed at this time
to lead the world into the fourth
Industrial Revolution because you pretty
much created this term we're seeing the
kind of technological strides that China
has made with your way with the 5G
technology do you believe that this
could potentially be China's time once
again
we we should make here again a let's say
a differentiation on the one hand we
have uh State capitalism on the other
hand we have shareholders or private
capitalism so it's a clash between two
systems I I believe that state
capitalism in the short term in the
short term provides a certain advantages
because you can mobilize in a
concentrated way a lot of resources to
reach a specific objective but I believe
that the future is not State capitalism
or shareholder capitalism the future is
what I call stake hold oil capitalism
which is combined with the social
responsibility
the last line there is the really scary
part stakeholder capitalism is combined
with this social this idea of social
responsibility this is ESG we've done
several shows on this Glenn Beck wrote a
fantastic book on it I had Vivek
ramaswamy on to talk about it this idea
that these companies and this is what
fascism is when governments work with
giant corporations to instill a
political belief on the people and
that's what they're doing so they get
these diversity Equity inclusion boards
at all of these big companies because
they're being socially responsible as
ESG wants as Klaus Schwab Palpatine
wants and then they hire based on race
and sexuality and gender and they make
sure that oh you've been vaxed so maybe
you'll get a promotion you weren't
vacced and you're white you're kind of
out man and a whole bunch more this is
exactly how it's working and what he
does this Klaus Schwab guy who of course
is unelected has no in in reality in the
reality of how things are supposed to
work should have no power over your life
he also comes off as a complete cartoon
character if you were if you were making
up the idea of the evil guy the evil
world leader I mean it's him the accent
it's all just perfect it's him but what
they then do is they have their little
world economic conferences obviously we
we covered the last one in Davos quite
extensively a couple weeks ago and then
they send the world leaders back to
their countries to Institute their
policies this is top down evil nonsense
we sent many many high-level American
officials there and then what happens
well you know we talked a little bit and
I did a show with Matthew Turman about
Brazil what's been going on in Brazil in
the election upheaval and of course
you're not seeing any of it on
mainstream media but now Brazil
basically has a socialist communist
government okay there has been a
complete takeover and freedom is hanging
on by a tenuous threat at Best in Brazil
here is their new prime minister this he
is a leftist socialist Lula saying that
you will not be able to receive
financial aid if you are not vaccinated
and I think you will see how these
things are all connected behave the way
we want as Klaus Schwab said there's a
social component to this get vaccinated
you'll get stuff from us don't get
vaccinated maybe you can't shop there
maybe you can't get a mortgage maybe you
can't get the car alone
Etc take a look
you know levels
foreign
[Applause]
um and if you don't do what he wants and
he said remember he's supposed to be the
Lefty the Socialist right these are
always supposed to be such nice people
does he seem very nice as he would
gladly take someone's child away from
them if they choose not to have this
poison injected into their child
whenever the state deems it necessary on
top of the fact that he clearly does not
think that and you can watch you can get
this one on me News Guard uh he clearly
himself doesn't think vaccines work if
you need 10 to 50 shots would you say I
would say 40 is probably roughly the
threshold like at the 39th shot when
you're getting shot number 40 and you're
like does this thing work what are we
doing here my arm hurts
um but these are bad people these are
bad people they are deeply connected and
and I think you can see how I'm trying
to paint you that picture of how it's
big government it's big Tech it's these
non-profits and then the government
itself funding these things and that's
how the lies all get laundered so how
can we connect that back to something
that's going on here in the United
States well one of the interesting
things happening is that the school
Choice Movement is picking up major
major steam uh it's happening in Iowa
it's happening in Arkansas uh we're
we're pushing for it here I hope that
DeSantis is going to get on it fully
here we have a better version of a
public school system here because we've
done so much to fight the woke but it is
happening from state to state where they
are deciding now and it's of course it's
all red states to fund students instead
of systems so you will get say a credit
of x amount of dollars and then you can
go okay I can either send my kid to the
public school I can send them to this
charter school I can send them to this
private school if I do one of these
things I may have to make up some extra
money but more choice so the school
schools then become competitive so
hopefully they start actually teaching
instead of indoctrinating but how is
that connected to all this well the
Democrats really don't want that why is
it that Democrats really want everybody
in public schools where they learn about
wokism and they learn that boys or girls
and chopping off your genitals is good
and they are indoctrinated with things
like the 1619 project and everything
else this seems to be happening in every
blue state that there is and here is
Katie Hobbs Katie Hobbs is the Democrat
Governor of Arizona and here she is
she's being asked the question about why
she doesn't support school choice choice
is good right I thought the Democrats
are supposed to be pro-choice but here
she is being asked why doesn't she
support school choice and she kind of
doesn't really get to do much of
anything here take a look I want to play
something that the State House Majority
Leader said in response to your plan I
think this was his response to your
State of the State address
we also think it's only right that
Arizona students have the choice that
Governor Hobbs had attending a private
school which she credits for helping her
build a better life a reference there to
the private Catholic High School that
you went to so why shouldn't all
students have a chance at what you said
was so important in your own life look I
grew up in a working class family this
was well before any of this public
assistance for private school existed
and my parents made that choice I begged
them to send me to public school and we
sacrificed a lot there were times in my
family that we were on food stamps and
so it wasn't it was a choice that they
made and they struggled to to make that
choice
um what I want is for every public every
student in the state of Arizona no
matter where they live to have access to
high quality public education and with
this Universal voucher system that's not
happening but if their system is failing
if their public school is failing no to
giving them a chance to go somewhere
else like you did
the the schools are failing because we
are failing to invest in them I actually
feel bad for Carrie Lake uh the fact
that carry Lake lost to that woman is
deeply depressing and she also does that
thing where you talk like this at the
end of every sentence so you don't
really have to say anything because
you're talking like this so then people
are like oh my God they talk like that
so they're obviously okay
um so you understand her parents did
everything they could if they were on
food stamps apparently but they somehow
could scraggle enough change to get her
out of the public school system because
they obviously were worried about the
public schools so they did everything
they could while they were eating their
little TV dinners uh and they sent her
to private school but she does not want
to give that opportunity to other people
but why is that and how is that
connected to what we're talking about
because what would be the best way of
brainwashing a generation taking an
entire generation of young people and
turning them into asexual purple-haired
socialist whack-a-doodles it would be by
sending them to State education where
the teachers now and Libs of tick tock
is constantly showing teachers uh saying
in essence this they are there to
reprogram the minds of these kids and it
is evil and it is dangerous and this is
the policy of the Democrat Party so
while folks like Hobbes try to force
Americans into State education
indoctrination we actually have other
leaders that are crushing that system
we've got to dissent this video can you
believe it yeah
so this college board like nobody
elected them to anything they're just
kind of there and they're providing
service and so you can either utilize
those services or not and so they've
provided these AP courses for a long
time uh but you know they're they're
probably some other vendors who may may
be able to do that job uh as good or
maybe even a lot better so I've already
talked with with Paul and I think the
legislature is going to look to to
reevaluate kind of how Florida is doing
that of course our universities can or
can't accept College Board courses for
credit maybe they'll do others and then
also just whether our universities do
the SAT versus the ACT I think they do
both but we're going to evaluate kind of
how all that that process goes uh but at
the end of the day we highlighted things
that were very problematic and I tell
you it wasn't just people like me saying
that across the political Spectrum
people were saying that like you know
this really is junk why don't we just do
and teach the things that matter why is
it always someone has to try to jam
their agenda down our throats
contrary to all of the harpies on The
View we showed you the videos yesterday
who were screaming that DeSantis doesn't
want anyone in Florida learn about
racism or civil rights or anything else
what he's doing is taking a AP course
where high school kids will get college
credit to learn about queer theory in
African-American studies while also
being taught that reparations are good
which is a political stance not
something that should be taught in high
school and a whole bunch of other
nonsense and all he's doing is pushing
back against it and that's what these
people hate most so the reason they
censor
the reason they censor clay Travis the
reason they write these ridiculous
reports and the reason that the
government funds these things to silence
us the reason they're doing that is
because too many of us are waking up I
don't know how long that can be
attainable position but to continue a
little bit further on this schooling
situation so Randy Weingart you know her
she is the president of the uh the
teachers union and here she is saying
she's very upset that the College Board
which that you know they handle these AP
classes she's very upset that they caved
to scary Ron DeSantis you know when I
first saw what the College Board did and
let me just confess I am an apgov
teacher I have thought but not
African-American studies but I've bought
a pick of
um and so I was disappointed as I said
that day with what the College Board had
taken out
oh so she was disappointed because she
wanted uh AP African-American studies to
teach gender queer theory if you were to
you know I took AP Government I think it
was I think it was American history or
AP Government I don't remember even the
title but I took it in 12th grade I
think I got three college credits
something like that I had to take a test
at the end and you have to pass the test
so that you get those college credits
but they weren't trying to indoctrinate
us we learned about things like the
separation of powers the Constitution
the Declaration of Independence all of
those old documents that we are founded
upon it was pretty good my teacher was
Mr Gessner he was fantastic one he was
the guy I loved the guy I absolutely
loved the guy
um so there she is and she's saying well
I'm an AP teacher too I teach apgov well
apgov is wildly different than this
nonsense but of course she's not going
to address what's actually and this is
exactly what they did on The View the
other day they never addressed what's
actually in any of the things they just
go with the bumper sticker thing don't
say gay well I'm gonna say gay nobody's
telling have to say gay lady so how do
we combat those who wish to censor us
the simple truth is just say enough just
tell the truth just be brave don't cave
and you will win because you will wake
more and more people up one of the guys
who I'm continually working on is Bill
Maher and here he is on his show
listening to Paul bagalla leftist
activist Paul De Gala who can't
understand why nothing's working right
from his own side and then bill has to
lay out some truth
Democrats and my fellow liberals it's
the people we supposedly care about are
the victims of crime it's those folks
who are voting for more security more
safety more and better cops and it's the
white liberals who want to defund the
police this is a big Achilles heel for
the Democrats is it not oh they need to
get out in front of it and they need to
I want a Democrat stand up and say you
know some people belong in jail
you know the rapists the murderers
I think that's very interesting I'm
gonna go out on a limb some people do
look I would honor to do the whole Bill
Maher thing but you know the fact that
he even called out the one person
clapped on that that some people deserve
in jail because Liberals are all afraid
of each other if if five people had
clapped then 20 people would have
clapped and then the whole audience
would have clapped on that but there was
one same probably conservative in the
crowd here's oh rapist should be in jail
that's pretty good
anybody for rapists in jail
Bill's going yeah rapists should be in
jail you morons I will give Bill a lot
of credit on that he is the only host I
have ever seen in television history who
attacks his own audience when they're
being stupid now again Bill always will
vote for Democrats I'm going to keep
working on him so be it but the point is
Paul begalla it's our guys it's us that
are doing this why don't we do better
than this well who are you always voting
for so bill needs to join the team
join the team man that rewards those who
protect us but are constantly hated on
who wrote the team that rewards the
people who are keeping Society going
while the other side decides to burn the
whole thing down
we got more DeSantis yeah he's hiring
more police officers and giving them
bonuses because they all want to move
here since they don't want to live in
New York or Cali anymore
legislature in this legislative session
we need to do bonuses for law
enforcement someone to fund
foreign
defund the police we're funding the
police and then some
and that is the Stark difference whether
it is at the education level whether it
is at the policing level that is the
Stark difference between what's
happening here in Florida and what's
happening in places like New York and
California and that's why they're
descent into that black hole of
Destruction or the videos that I showed
you of all the drug users in San
Francisco it's like these it comes from
State education it comes from lack of
personal responsibility it comes from
high taxes and high regulation so people
can't start small businesses so they
can't have their dreams so then they
become dependent on the system and they
they aren't they literally aren't as
happy they aren't as fulfilled in their
lives and that's why there is this Urban
Decay in those places and that's why it
is freaking flourishing right here and
that's why if DeSantis runs his theme
his theme should be simple make America
Florida that's it that is the answer we
have it but at the end of the day which
regardless of which way the political
wind is blowing you must fight for
what's right we have had too many people
that happen are the Republicans getting
balls right now it does seem that way
and what's happening even as that
happens as more of us wake up from the
mainstream media Slumber as more people
get red pilled and everything else the
Democrats are having trouble explaining
their policies right that's why Katie
Hobbs who we showed you a moment ago the
the governor of Arizona she refused to
debate Carrie Lake now she won social
she won't debate next time either if she
runs again but this is what they do they
have the media behind them so they very
rarely have to explain themselves so now
Chuck Schumer
Chuck Schumer who 20 years ago was a
decent moderate liberal he's just a
leftist he's just got nothing left
there's just nothing left he's also
related to Amy Schumer which is just
disgusting did you know that I'm not
making that up they're cousins or
something yeah or he's her uncle or
something anyway he went on The View
because uh they were having trouble
explaining why despite Biden's
vivaciousness and energy and all of
those things why is it that people don't
seem to support the guy so chuck had to
run some cover
President Biden State of the Union
doubled as a soft launch soft launch for
2024 and President Biden has made
historic accomplishments which you were
speaking to in job growth Health Care
infrastructure but in ABC News poll uh I
know earmuffs a whoopee uh says that the
voters are even less enthused about
Biden running again than Trump now can
you explain the disconnect between what
we are seeing in the successes and what
the polling is showing I think first you
can't always believe polling thank you
hey there was a poll in 1983 that said
Ronald Reagan would get clobbered and of
course he won a huge Victory but second
I think part of it is that we now have
to make sure the American people they've
read what we have done yeah but they
haven't
so October doesn't have a neck
he's just ahead on a body you might want
to look into a neck extension or you
know those women that put the Rings so
they get that long neck we gotta get one
of those for Chuck
um okay so fine you know my feelings
about the poles you don't always have to
believe in the polls but what I thought
was interesting about that clip is you
see uh they're not getting the results
right they see that people aren't into
the Biden thing okay he stood there he
didn't collapse his brain didn't explode
so be it but they're not seeing enough
people just falling for it on top of the
fact that him running as an 84 year old
or whatever it be would be the most
giant ridiculous farce of all time there
already is a massive conspiracy running
in the white house which is that they
drug him for these things there is no
doubt about it it will come out one day
News Guard you can watch this show right
now and said Dave Rubin says that
they're drugging Joe Biden and yes they
are drugging Joe Biden I don't need the
receipts it is obvious okay there's
something wrong with him if he was your
grandfather and constantly babbling and
confused and shaking hands with ghosts
and telling stories that made no sense
you would say grandma or you'd say mom
can we get Grandpa to the doctor okay so
we know something's not right there but
what's interesting about that clip is
they they constantly carry water for the
guy and then a day or two after the
State of the Union they bring out Chuck
Schumer so that he can run cover for him
too let's just try to imagine if this
was three years ago and Donald Trump was
giving the state of the union and let's
say Donald Trump's poll numbers weren't
that great much like Biden's do you
think they'd bring out Ted Cruz to be
like Ted Ted the guy is so freaking
great lowest all-time black unemployment
lowest all-time Hispanic unemployment
all these peace deals in the Middle East
the stock market's going crazy but
people don't get it Ted could you help
us out with this Donald Trump guy
you got it guys you got it one day I'm
going to do a show where I just point at
the crowd I'm just going to point at the
camera and people will understand what
I'm saying by that because that's I
think how how sharp our audience is you
you know with certain I can give you a
look and it's like you got what I'm
saying you get it you're wise people
that's why you watch the program if
you'd like to join us for the post game
show please do join right now at
reubenreport.locals.com we'll be live in
about 30 seconds if you have not
subscribed yet at rumble.com Ruben
report go ahead and do that our full
interview with Robert Malone is up right
now part one with Pete bagozian all
about political differences
and and how you can maintain a
friendship throughout that because as I
said Pete and I watched the State of
Union not together but I'm watching him
live tweet it and he's telling me how
great Biden is and I'm going off on
Biden and then coincidentally I had him
on the show he was in studio here in
Miami the next day so we just released
part one on that how can you maintain
friendship with people who you just see
things in such a different way with uh
that's what Pete and I did for about an
hour I think you'll enjoy that and then
later today uh my full interview it's
about a half hour with Spencer clave and
you guys know Spencer he's on the panels
quite often son of Andrew Cleveland from
the daily wire uh he just wrote a new
book all about how to save the West uh
he's really a great thinker I think he's
got a bright future in front of him uh
that will be up later today uh we leave
you with a cold close and I'll see you
momentarily but look my number one
priority is saving lives
saving lives that has to be my number
one priority and it has since the time
that I took my oath
[Music]